hi everyone today I'm here with Siobhan
hi we're going to be talking all about
the physics Olympiad again we've just
made a video looking through an exam and
seeing what kind of questions are
involved but now we're going to talk
more about maybe some tips for how to
actually sit one of these exams how to
do well and what it's all about
okay so Siobhan you've been involved in
the physics Olympiad you've done it
before you've been a team leader and
you're still involved with the
Australian team so tell me a little bit
what is the physics Olympiad to you so
the International physics Olympiad is
competition for high school students and
it's held every year in a different
country around the world and it attracts
national teams of around yet five
students per team from nearly 90
countries so it's it's quite big and
it's part of the International Science
Olympiad movement so there are other
competitions for other disciplines like
chemistry and arts as well so you can go
to this Olympics in a way and become a
gold medal physicist is that how it
works you get bragging right yep so the
prize is these medals yeah yeah there
are gold medals if you finish in the top
around 10% of students so here it's so
competitive to get there like there's I
think thousands of Australian students
that's it but likewise around the world
so many students trying to prepare for
these exams and get and
ya know sort of the numbers around it
yeah exactly so the selection process to
make it onto a national team can always
be as tough as the competition itself so
in Australia we have a few thousand
students every year in year 10 and year
11 who sit the national exam through
Australian Science Olympiad in countries
such as America and the UK similar kind
of numbers and then you have really
quite strong countries such as China and
India where they have tens or even
hundreds of thousands of students
sitting their national exams or to try
and make it to the next stage which is
usually a training camp at a university
where you learn a lot of extra physics
that you wouldn't get to see usually in
school so maybe like you actually really
do have to train like an Olympian for
one of these things so a lot of studying
would have to go into this I'm sort of
wondering if a student is preparing for
this Olympiad how does that differ from
what they're learning to pass their high
school exams or what they're like
learning alongside this is it a big
extra commitment I would say that
preparing for the Olympiad is an extra
commitment there is a syllabus out there
for the International physics Olympiad
which is usually pitch to those first
year university in the level hmm so you
do have to cover a lot of extra topics
and clearly putting in the hours
practicing hard physics problems is is
important in order to learn the kind of
skills and techniques that you can
employ not just on paper but the
experiment as well like it's hard for a
student at high school to get a huge
exposure to a variety of different
experiments and so that's where some
partnerships with universities and
things really you can actually get
trained on some of the equipment not
just reading how the experiments were
yeah but then furthermore if you're
interested in like playing around with
electronics and sort of building your
own physics kits at home then that will
stand you in really good stead yeah okay
do you think doing well in this exam is
a matter of practicing sometimes that is
the case what exams like the more
practice problems you can get your hands
on the better you'll just do because
they tend to repeat things is that the
case here or is it where you really need
the understanding I think for the
physics Olympiad you need the practice
but you also need that understanding in
order to drive you to practice yeah okay
if you're curious about how something
works or what's this solution to this
really unusual physics situation like
then that motivates student seek out
those tricky problems
but certainly the physics Olympiad
problems year two here they're usually
pretty unique especially written well
ahead of the actual competition and
they're kind of really kept and
top-secret so you'll be seeing some
unusual kinds of physics that yeah you
would not come across in a you know
standard high school textbook for sure
okay
well maybe let's get practical because
you've got so much experience with the
exam you might have some tips or advice
for like how to best prepare maybe let's
talk about getting into like your
national team first like how should you
be preparing for that well I definitely
have a look on the internet to see what
the national selection process is for
your country so in Australia we have one
exam in here that has a short
multiple-choice section and then some
sort of short to long answer physics
problems as well and those past papers
are all online and we also have a
platform called Olympiads online where
you can practice solutions and get
feedback on how you're going and talk to
other students who are preparing for
this national exam too so yeah see what
the situation is in your own country but
there's
there's probably an existing science
olympiad organization you can yeah yeah
okay
what about like maybe you've been
successful getting that far how do you
actually do well at this paper like how
do you walk into it and just do well so
I think it's important to put that in
context in terms of every year is maybe
400 students that turn up to the
International physics or in powder
they're all pretty capable and pretty
bright but still this exam will manage
to stump many of them like in the 2016
paper in the theory section all the gold
medalists so the students in the top 10%
they all got above 70% but then the
number who get above 90% is like smaller
again so it's definitely a tough a tough
exam so having the understanding of
physics kind of first principles and
being able to be flexible in your
thinking and bring lots of different
bits of physics together on the day
yeah I think that's how you go now a
favorite of persistence as well because
the exams of are really long and yet to
see an experiment through for five hours
you know stopping is yeah it's a tough
tough thing to do
yeah I think the exam we've just looked
at it was held in Zurich and Switzerland
in that year and they had a bit at the
end about the LHC the particle collider
there so maybe it's a good idea to look
at maybe countries specific you know
physics that's that you know is in that
country or physicists maybe yeah for
sure I think the people who are writing
the exams often take inspiration from
the physics that's in that part of the
world or maybe that a physicist from
that country has has gone on to study so
yeah the Large Hadron Collider question
was a great example of that
yeah Switzerland and you think Geneva
and anything on Collider and yeah as
part of their preparation for the
international physics team that students
might also participate in a regional
competition like the Asian physics
Olympiad and that's coming to Australia
next year it'll be held in Adelaide so
I'm really excited for to see to see
what kind of problems the Australians
can come up with so the people that do
well and say the physics Olympiad do
they tend to go on to become physics
majors is it a way to identify great
physicists well in my own case I've gone
on to study physics at uni and now I
have a job working as a business
and I think that was really started by
getting involved in the physics Olympiad
I think more broadly it definitely
encourages students to discover they
have a capability in science to follow
that up and see where it takes them but
there's more to doing physics research
than doing it in five hour bursts and
working with like clearly set out
problems like and you have to find your
own problems and troubleshoot and be
creative over a much longer period of
time so I think it's a great tool to
encourage students to go further into
science but I don't think it's
necessarily about identifying yeah I
think research physics is a whole
different beast - whether it's exam
physics attorney level or high school
exams but I sort of agree anything that
you can do well in that sort of physics
related really inspires you don't want
to go down that path so like I didn't do
the Olympiad but I did similar sort of
things locally at high school and you
know just doing them made me want to
become their physics major so yeah
furthermore you're meeting others same
kind of passions and values as yourself
and then that's a whole nother
motivating factor and I think that's
this one of the strongest parts about
real intelligence really held with this
atmosphere of bringing different people
from different cultures together who all
like physics it's what we have in common
and that's that's a really nice you do
you sort of have any anecdotes about how
many people you knew back then who've
become physics majors like a lot a
little bit yeah definitely like on my
physics team
I've got a teammate who's now doing his
PhD in LIGO so gravity Wow and I've also
got physics Olympiad friends who have
gone on to cosmology plasma physics
teaching other great unions around the
world and and Sciences and so driven by
international collaborations and I
reckon it's excellent to go to the
physics link out of the earth
what kind of vibrations are gonna come
out of this yeah where people are gonna
go with their science all right
is there any more tips maybe you'd like
to share any any last advice about the
time oh I think I just encouraged like
teen teen students if you're in yeah
like you're ten or year eleven so that's
the Australian school years for 15 for
17 year olds if you're keen on physics
and you're looking for a little
something to extend yourself yeah why
not give it a go yeah thank you so long
and thank you guys for watching thank
you
you